what was supposed to be a saturday night
at a bar turned to tragedy for the
soweto family
suny sila golempi's 19 year old son
symptom bile was killed when three
gunmen entered the bar where he'd gone
to play pool
his family heard the gunshots from their
home
it's painful for me what happened to my
child really painful for me
and he was the only son in this home we
had high hopes for him
symptom billy was one of 15 people
killed at this bar most of them lived in
the area
the bar has now been closed as police
investigate what happened
they say they haven't yet established a
motive but many blame poor policing and
the proliferation of guns
timbit lamini lost both her son and
nephew in the attack she's too
devastated to talk
for people living in this area we hear
gunshots every day we live in fear every
day there is not a single day that
passes without us hearing gunshots
says people are buried every week
as shocking as the attack was for people
here it's not an isolated incident two
other bars were attacked in recent days
one in the kwazulu-natal province and
the other in a township east of
johannesburg more than 20 people were
killed
as a community reels in shock families
tried to absorb what's happened their
devastation worsened by the unaffordable
cost of bearing their loved ones familia
muller soweto south africa